it is seven o'clock good to have you
with us russia is ramping up the
rhetoric with talk of world war three
this morning plus there is a cost of
living cabinet the pm wants ideas about
how to help people pay their bills what
are they considering plenty to put to
the armed forces minister james hippie
in a few minutes time plus the shadow
secretary of state for transport louise
hague plus the twitter taker triggering
some terrorist tweets we'll have all the
fallout to elon musk's deal with a
former british army intelligence officer
who has some concerns it is tuesday the
26th of april
a real danger of world war iii the
warning from the russian foreign
minister as new footage shows the
suburban wasteland left in eastern
ukraine
an extraordinary moment of kindness in
kharkiv we'll bring you a special report
just after 8 o'clock
dangerous for democracy fears after
twitter agrees with elon musk a 44
billion deal
lockdown link scientists reveal a new
line of inquiry in to what could be
behind a rise in hepatitis cases in
children
we'll show you the new body cam footage
released from the alec baldwin film set
where a cinematographer was shot
including this exchange with the armorer
we'll be reporting from lancashire as
concerns grow for the welfare of 33 year
old katie kenyon last seen three days
ago
spiking danger the calls for a change in
the law to make it a criminal offence we
speak to victims
i couldn't support myself i've i started
being sick
and i i personally don't remember
anything really of the night
also ahead on the programme
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
love it the bristol band porter said are
set to make a rare return to the stage
as part of a ukrainian benefit concert
in their hometown i'll be speaking to
one of the group a little later on
and we'll be speaking to two guys who
have lost a total of 22 stone together
through a football focused weight loss
program
[Music]
morning all uh we begin with a warning
from the russian foreign minister who
said that nato is in essence engaged in
a war with russia as he warned there was
also real danger of it turning into
world war iii all this with the un
secretary general due to hold talks with
russian president vladimir putin later
today so let's take a quick look at some
of the latest developments
the u.s defense secretary is hosting
a group of nato defense ministers and
senior military officials at an air base
in germany our own defense secretary ben
wallace will be present
meanwhile the government says 15 000
russian troops have been killed since
the invasion began
uh well in in a tv interview sergey
lavrov has said that the west's military
support for ukraine means that nato is
in essence engaged in conflict with
russia
and well here is what uh sergey lavrov
said the danger is serious it is real it
should not be underestimated let's see
if we can speak to mark stone he's
joining us now from dinipro in the east
of the country good to see you this
morning mark i mean what are you and
indeed others in dinipro making of that
which we've been hearing from sergey
lavrov world war three proxy conflict
from with nato
well you know
at ground level um they're looking at
this uh as a as a daily struggle and
they're not looking at the big picture
uh they're not looking
at these
to this talk of world war three um there
are so many different front lines in
this war it's often uh it's misleading
to see it as a singular front line and
along the east of the country with the
ukrainians on one side and the russians
on the other it isn't um in towns and
villages across the east across the
north and across the south there are
multiple front lines multiple villages
multiple fights taking place
and that is ongoing every single day
we've traveled um to the far east of the
country um to towns that are pretty much
encircled now by the russians one town
lisa chance one road in and one road out
if you are on the ukrainian side and
there is real concern in that town that
it will be
within the next days or weeks it will be
encircled completely and it will be
another town that falls to russia
another town that is destroyed there are
reports as well overnight of the
russians amassing troops to the south of
here about an hour and a half's drive to
the south of where we are and in dunipro
where they will attempt
potentially over the course of the next
few days and weeks and remember it takes
them a long time to take these these
cities because their supply lines are
not good and their morale is not good
but there will be an attempt
it's thought
to push north effectively a pincer
movement very traditional military
doctrine they're pushing from the east
they've got forces in the north they've
got forces in the south and they're
trying to to unite those those two
divisions of their military and that
from there they would push um west and i
think that along with so many other
challenges will be front and center in
ramstein air base as defence ministers
meet this morning
mark many thanks indeed
very pleased to say we can now speak
once again to the armed forces minister
james heapey who's joining us from
central london mister he very good
morning so you do hope you're well um i
wonder if we might start with that which
we were just hearing from mark the the
action that is taking place in the east
of the country i mean boris johnson
himself has already expressed concern
for the donbass region i mean is there
no inevitability
to the russians taking territory in that
part of the country
i don't think there's an inevitability
at all i mean i think the last time that
i had the privilege of uh speaking for
the government in the morning was about
two or three weeks ago and
we were reflecting then on how uh
imminent the demise of mario paul may be
and yet those fighters that are in mario
paul defending it so heroically are
still going through later and they are
soaking up a huge amount of russian
combat power as that defense continues
so um i think that what we will see in
the donbass is a very different type of
conflict to the one that we saw
around kiev i think we'll see a conflict
between two forces that are much more
evenly balanced uh where the ukrainians
have the advantage of defensive
positions that have been dug in and
prepared over the last eight years and
that's going to make it an
extraordinarily difficult nut for the
russians to crack um and i think that
with all of the support that the
ukrainians are getting from around the
world there's every chance that the
ukrainians can see them off
we know that the ukrainians certainly
have been fighting and fighting hard
your boss ben wallace was briefing mps
yesterday viewers can see on the screen
perhaps as many as 15 000 russian
personnel have been killed perhaps as
many as 30 of the battalion tactical
groups
yeah i mean that's right those are the
numbers that the ukrainians report and
that is and that's vast that is nearly
three times as many uh
dead as russia suffered in the first
chechen war
and
and that is that is
nobody should rejoice in that that's 15
000 russian families who haven't got
their son or husband or brother coming
home
but
people in russia should be clear that
that is because
the russian plan has been
defined by incredible hubris massive
political interference in military plan
making and we're seeing exactly the same
now
where there is pressure from moscow to
deliver a victory by the 9th of may so
that putin can have a nice parade
through red square
even though that makes no military sense
the weather in the donbass over the last
week or so has been absolutely awful and
so driving the russian army to launch an
offensive now
simply so putin can have a nice day in
the sun on may the 9th it's just going
to cost russia thousands more lives now
if you're on the side of the ukrainians
and you want the ukrainians to succeed
in defending their territory that
russian hubris is a massive massive
advantage for ukraine but if i was a
russian family i'd be deeply concerned
that those in the kremlin were not
acting in my interests
on that point then minister what more
can you tell us about the additional
assistance that we're providing a lot of
kind of speculation perhaps informed
speculation in the papers about storm or
vehicles being sent perhaps as uh
providing some form of radar as well
what more can you tell us on that
well that's exactly right and you know
the secretary of state has been very
very clear that russia only has itself
to blame because every time we have gone
up a gear in terms of what we are
providing it is a direct consequence of
the way that russia has conducted its
operations
in ukraine
now storma is a air defense facility
that is mounted on an armored vehicle we
think that that's necessary
in order to
give greater protection to ukrainian
ground forces and the civilian
populations
in some cities uh we have been scouring
the earth for
uh 152 millimeter artillery ammunition
which is
the artillery ammunition that the
ukrainians would need for their existing
guns
but we've also now been working with
allies around the world to provide them
with uh 155 millimeter which is the nato
standard caliber
and that means that hundreds of
thousands more artillery rounds are now
flowing in from the united states
particularly to ukraine there are
countries in eastern europe that are
giving up sophisticated air defense
systems hundreds of tanks i mean this is
an amazing effort and the uk has been to
the fore in corralling it
the the the response though from the
russians in particular then the foreign
minister sergey lavrov uh warning that
that this could be as on the precipice
of world war three already suggesting
that russia is not fighting ukraine it's
it's fighting nato i mean obviously that
clearly removes you know the ukrainians
agency and all of this but i wonder what
you make of the at the brinksmanship in
terms of the rhetoric about potentially
your third global conflict well look i
mean there's a couple of points of
distinction firstly the donor community
is not nato nato uh has been involved in
reinforcing its eastern flank so a lot
of the deployments of our troops ships
and aircraft to eastern europe are very
much under the nato flag but the donor
effort is something that is being
brought together by countries that are
from yes many of them are from nato but
others are from beyond the australians
the kiwis the canadians uh sorry the
canadians are in natick um and and so
you know that is uh it's not nato that
is doing the the the military aid but
sergey lavrov might also reflect that
the reason that there is a war in
ukraine right now
is because russia rolled over the
borders of a sovereign country and
started to invade their territory nato
is not an expansionist offensive
alliance nato is a defensive alliance
and all of this noise from moscow about
somehow
uh their their attack on ukraine being a
response to nato aggression is just
utter utter nonsense um minister i
wonder if we can move away from from you
from your brief now and to perhaps the
kind of the biggest individual issue
facing your politics and indeed the
public uh domestically the the cost of
living we understand that there is to be
a cost of living cabinet today the prime
minister very keen to get as many ideas
as possible you know for for as little
money as possible given what we've been
spending over the past few years
what is the hope uh from this meeting
this morning
well look i mean the reason that the
meeting is happening and the reason that
so many meetings on the cost of living
happen in government every single day
is because the moment that you go out
and knock on doors in your constituency
what you find
is that that is the thing that
hard-working families across the united
kingdom are most concerned about the
cost of living is getting to such a
point now where even people on good
wages are struggling to make ends meet
and they are looking to the government
to help them with solutions now what
they were deciding cabinet this morning
is for them and it's certainly not for
me to to try and trail but already for
this year alone the government's put 22
billion pounds of targeted funding in to
support those who are struggling most
with the cost of living and the fact
that cabinet is meeting today to discuss
it more shows you just how seriously
this is taken by the prime minister the
chancellor and the rest of their
colleagues in cabinet but it isn't the
simple truth though i mean i've read the
article that the the son was briefed on
on the cabinet meeting taking place this
morning and the kind of the one of the
biggest announcement one of the biggest
policies that was was flagged up in the
article was removing tariffs on rice now
i understand that that will help you
know but we're talking pennies and not
pounds i mean isn't the simple truth
there's not an awful lot
that the government can do without
spending money
well i mean
there's no doubt about it that these
interventions are expensive 22 billion
pounds of government intervention to
assist in uh to assist with families
with their cost of living is already
huge there'll be other levers that
government can pull and you know the not
no one of them will be a golden bullet
but cumulatively if you can provide
people with lots of small savings across
their cost of living then cumulatively
that does start to make a difference so
i wouldn't i wouldn't sniff at the
removal of a tariff on a particular food
type because if that sits alongside uh
you know a resistance a reduction in uh
fuel duty at the pumps which has
happened if that sits alongside a rising
of the personal allowance an increase in
the national living wage you know
cumulatively you can start to see and
you know and assisting people with their
energy bills cumulative you can start to
see how that starts to ease the pressure
on the families who are struggling the
most minister i i promise you i am not
being sniffy about cheaper rice you have
no idea how much curry i eat i do
however want us to conclude on just a on
a couple of related topics around around
freedom of speech um angela rayner of
course you will by now have seen that uh
the article such as it was uh in the
mail on sunday i i have to admit i feel
slightly uncomfortable this morning
yesterday clearly we were talking with
your colleague chris phil the article
itself misogynistic sexist and all the
rest of it and then we hear that the
speaker of the house of commons has
summoned the mail on sunday's editor for
a meeting presumably to chastise him
does that sit easily with you you know
the speaker of the house of commons
summoning a journalist to explain their
actions
well look
lindsay is fiercely independent and
rightly so you know he is the speaker of
the house of commons and he must do what
he thinks is in parliament's interest
i would just reflect that you know i
don't think that the speaker is
trying to limit freedom of speech in
fact my understanding was i wasn't in
the chamber yesterday to hear him say it
firsthand my understanding is that he
made the point of saying that he wants
to protect freedom of speech and that
the role of the press uh lobby in
parliament is hugely important um but
there are female colleagues in the house
of commons on all sides of the house who
have to put up with a level of
sexism misogyny every day that frankly
is unfair
it is a disadvantage to them that i
don't have to face as a male member of
parliament or a male minister and i just
can't believe that in 2022 we're in a
place where
the story that was written on sunday was
was written i can't believe that one of
my colleagues the story was written
because your colleagues i think it's
despicable
and i i i just find it outrageous that
that colleague who who
sits within a party that has delivered
two female prime ministers that has two
women in the great offices of state that
is surrounded by amazingly capable
female mps on the conservative benches
as well as over on the labour benches
too i just i just don't know what
parliament that they think they sit in i
just i find the whole thing ridiculous
offensive i'm sorry for angela um and i
you know if the speaker is going to put
a shot across the bowels about the way
that women in parliament are being
reported that's a good thing i have no
doubt that he is protecting freedom of
speech and he won't want to see that
imprint but i do think that westminster
has just got itself into a mess and it
it looks awful
yeah
to continue with the freedom of speech
and theme what what are your thoughts
about the the taking private of uh
social media platform at twitter by elon
musk i mean the bill's certainly up
there and the board obviously still has
to agree but do you have any concerns
about the richest man in the world
owning perhaps one of the most
significant social media platforms
well i i the government doesn't have a
view the government will let this go
through as as a as a transaction
but there is
um i think you know elon musk has made
some good noises about being a protector
of freedom of speech i think i've also
heard him say some stuff about uh ending
the anonymity of the trolls on on
twitter uh and you know those of us who
use twitter
as part of our jobs
will know that twitter can be an
absolute sewer sometimes because people
do have anonymity and that makes them
very brave uh when they have anonymity
um i if twitter is going to be cleaned
up as a platform
uh be
somewhere where freedom of speech is
championed um but the anonymous
anonymous abuse becomes uh more
difficult then that's a good thing but
that's my view and the government's view
is that this is a this is a takeover bit
on which we have no view at the moment
jmcp great to have you on the program as
always thanks for joining us thanks now
thank you
well as we were just mentioning there
the billionaire elon musk has struck a
deal to buy twitter and a takeover worth
getting this 44 billion dollars guys u.s
correspondent greg milam has the detail
even a few days ago it seemed elon
musk's dream of owning twitter was
doomed to fail once again the world's
richest man has shown how dangerous it
is to bet against him in a statement
confirming the takeover musk said free
speech is the bedrock of a functioning
democracy and twitter is the digital
town square where matters vital to the
future of humanity are debated i also
want to make twitter better than ever by
enhancing the product with new features
making the algorithms open source to
increase trust defeating the spam bots
and authenticating all humans twitter
has tremendous potential i look forward
to working with the company and the
community of users to unlock it
cargo dragon take flight but what will a
man who's turned his other pet projects
like tesla and spacex into world beaters
due to a platform that is a voice for
millions i certainly think it's
beginning of a significant new chapter
for twitter and i think that the
platform
has got a lot of problems and this could
be the solution it's been crying out for
but i fear that elon musk will bring um
lots of the controversy that him and his
account and already uh brings with it
and i think that that sort of attention
that sort of those sorts of problems are
ones that twitter could do without and i
think that users and staff at twitter
will probably be very frightened today
of what the future holds for the
platform with elon musk in charge it'll
be a big change too for twitter's
employees in offices like these who now
find they have one of the most mercurial
and unpredictable of bosses and they
like everyone else might ponder what it
means when the richest person on the
planet has control of one of its most
influential of platforms
all that remains open to question elon
musk has promised he will make twitter
better the world wonders what that will
look like greg milam sky news los
angeles
i think it's fair to say there has been
a range of reaction to the sale let's
take a look at some of it uh starting
with florida's republican governor ron
desantis he of course tweeted this the
offer to buy twitter is a good deal for
shareholders and raises the prospect
that the platform will be a place where
free speech can thrive not a tool for
narrative enforcement perhaps predicting
the return of donald trump to twitter
meanwhile democratic senator elizabeth
warren labelled the deal dangerous for
our democracy as she said billionaires
like elon musk play by a different set
of rules than everyone accumulating
power for their own game
bilbar led the u.s justice department's
anti-trust division under president
obama suggested it might not be a done
deal he said that regulators would look
hard to see whether there's a risk to
competition and to consumers
that story of course featuring in the
papers here's the metro it leads with
billionaire elon musk winning his 35
billion pound takeover bid for twitter
the eye reports that the bonf the prime
minister is considering what it calls a
bonfire of policies to appease angry
tory backbenchers the paper hears that
two-thirds of the policies planned for
may's queen's speech are now at risk
here's the telegraph it links a recent
surge in hepatitis cases in young
children to the effects of lockdown and
social distancing
and on the front of the sun pubs will be
allowed to stay open longer during the
queen's platinum jubilee weekend
still to come on the show i'll be
speaking to labour's shadow transport
secretary louise haye as the party
demands an emergency budget from the
government to deal with the cost of
living crisis
i'll chat to a former british
intelligence officer and cyber expert
about elon musk's twitter takeover
and as beijing faces the prospect of
another lockdown wheelchair with the
world health organization's special
envoy for the global covert 19 response
dr david nabarro about the different
approaches countries are taking
in reaction to the pandemic
now u.s police have released crime scene
photos and body cam footage from the
investigation into the fatal on-set
shooting allegedly involving alec
baldwin the cinematographer helena
hutchins was killed in october after the
actor was apparently handed a gun with
live ammunition during filming
this isn't in here
yeah well this body cam footage here
that's alec baldwin at the back of short
there you saw him taking time out to
answer his mobile phone
after the incident
what is your name
[Music]
well this is hannah gutierrez also
captured on a police body cam in the
immediate aftermath of the shooting
hannah was responsible for the safety of
guns on set she's now suing the weapons
provider alleging he supplied a
mismarked box of ammunition containing
live rounds we also heard from the
police on the body cam footage
the last i got from her was it went in
through her right and out the left back
our 42 year old cinematographer helena
hutchins was killed in the incident
following her death work on rust was
suspended indefinitely
10 children in the uk have needed a
liver transplant as a result of
developing acute hepatitis as cases
continues to continue to rise as guys
madeleine ratcliffe is in the newsroom
for us has been taking a closer look and
the suggestion is madeline that this is
somehow linked to lockdown exactly how
well it's because there's far more cases
than normal we've had as many cases in
three months as you normally have in a
year 114 and it's actually a more severe
strain and
corona sorry uh hepatitis is a fairly
common
illness in small children not often very
serious but this seems different and one
of the explanations that is it's caused
by a different virus to normal the
adenovirus which in itself is common it
causes pneumonia sometimes cold and
flu-like symptoms uh conjunctivitis and
diarrhoea and vomiting so children often
get it but it's very rarely very rarely
leads to something like hepatitis it's
only in very rare cases where there's a
complication and the theory is at the
moment that because children were locked
down they weren't um mixing as much had
far less exposure to this very common
virus that's what has
meant that they are more susceptible to
getting um ill and getting quite
severely ill from it um this is what the
woman who is investigating the surge in
hepatitis for the uk health and security
agency dr mira chand
said about it she's quoted in the
telegraph saying we have a co-factor
affecting a particular age group of
young children which is either rendering
that infection more severe or causing it
to trigger some kind of immunopathology
this could include a lack of prior
exposure of that particular age group
during the formative stages they've gone
through during the pandemic so children
staying at home far less mixing which is
normally how they're exposed to these
common viruses and that has led to this
it's one of those very unfortunate and
unexpected uh consequences potentially
of lockdown
madeleine thanks very much indeed
let's take a look at some of the day's
other headlines and concerns are growing
for the welfare of 33 year old katie
kenyon last seen in lancashire three
days ago police are continuing to
question a 50 year old man from burnley
on suspicion of kidnap detectives have
been granted another 36 hours for
questioning
summer holidays are at risk for millions
of britons due to huge delays in
renewing outdated passports ministers
suburged holidaymakers to get their
applications in as soon as possible with
one mp saying his constituents are
having to cancel holidays miss funerals
and rearrange visits the surge in demand
comes after the lifting of covered
restrictions and delays in passport
renewals during lockdown
a man in his late twenties has been
questioned over the fatal stabbings of
four people in south east london and
remains in custody emergency services
were called to a house in birmingham
yesterday morning where three women and
a man were pronounced dead at the scene
one of the victims relatives was
they don't there it
she's a very lovely lady
mps have warned that drink spiking will
remain an invisible crime unless more is
done to improve awareness and support
victims a report by the home affairs
committee calls for spiking a person's
drink to be made a specific criminal
offence sky's north of england
correspondent jared tubb reports
the beginning of a night out in
yorkshire for a 20 year old earlier this
month it ended with her in hospital
convinced her drink had been spiked i
just went all floppy i couldn't support
myself i started being sick
and i i personally don't remember
anything really of the night and i was
carried out by bouncers i don't remember
that
and bearing in mind i'd only had the
three glasses of wine that's not enough
for me to just forget the whole night
mps say it's a heinous crime that should
be a specific offence and the police
should do more to gather data on spikers
the select committee stresses that no
one knows how prevalent spiking is a
spokesman told me they can't even be
sure the statistics they use in their
own report gathered from twitter are
accurate
i think because the drugs leave the
system quickly
more action is needed to collect a
sample under chain of evidence as soon
as possible and analyze it as soon as
possible because i think then that is
the only way
we'll get hard evidence that this is a
true problem
the government says it is taking the
issue of spiking seriously we're working
with the police across the whole country
to make sure that they've got the right
response and they can tackle the
perpetrators of these crimes and we also
are looking at whether there is a need
for a specific offence for spiking
those who believe they are spiking
victims rarely go to the police this
report wants that to change to lead to
more prosecutions
[Applause]
gerard tubbs sky news york
gotta love this the first ever space
tourists have returned from the
international space station uh let's
take a quick look uh well this was the
first time uh that nasa opened its space
hatches to tourists three businessmen
paid
55 million dollars for a week up on the
iss which was extended to nearly 17 days
due to the weather conditions nice
holiday if you can get it time to see
how the weather's looking down here
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
rest of the week mostly dry as high
pressure extends from the north however
it will be on the cool side and it's
been a mostly dry but chilly start this
evening a touch of frost and some fog
patches cloudier across parts of
scotland and northeast england with some
light showers overall most places having
bright spells and light winds today
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
this is sad news a japanese woman
recognized as the oldest woman in the
world has died at the age of 119
just months short of reaching 120.
kate tanaka was certified by the
guinness world records as the oldest
living person in 2019 she died in
southern japan where she spent her whole
life
with ms tanaka's passing the mantle of
world's oldest woman now rests with the
french nun lucille rondon aged 118.
i confidently predict i will not be
reaching at that particular age let's
take a quick look at some of the great
pictures in the papers this morning
first up the guardian has this picture
of greenpeace activists squaring up to a
russian oil tanker in order to prevent
it from delivering russian oil into the
norwegian capital of oslo one of them
holding a sign that says
oil fuels
war and just another example we've been
seeing in ukraine that you know
sometimes
small people the small guy can actually
win a big war the telegraph if we had to
take another look as an example an
incredible example of camouflage in the
animal world you might just be able to
make out the two eyes there and there of
a snow leopard blending in with its
surroundings in the tibetan highlands
can't believe you managed to capture
that one
and a slightly less threatening creature
in the times now
i'm not the only sky news presenter who
likes dogs at cookie the cockapoo
enjoying himself on a walk amongst the
bluebells this is exactly what i look
like at five o'clock in the morning
after my third coffee still to come on
the program i will be speaking to a
former british intelligence officer
about potential security concerns
following elon musk's takeover of
twitter that's coming next
welcome back as the russian foreign
minister warns that nato is effectively
engaged in a war with russia putin's
forces continue to increase their
attacks in the east of ukraine a little
earlier i spoke to the armed forces
minister james heapey he told me it was
not guaranteed that russia would take
territory in the donbass region
i don't think there's an inevitability
at all i mean uh i think the last time
that i had the privilege of uh speaking
for the government in the morning was
about two or three weeks ago and
we were reflecting then on how
uh imminent the demise of mario paul may
be and yet those fighters that are in
mario paul defending it so heroically
are still going i think we'll see a
conflict between two forces that are
much more evenly balanced
where the ukrainians have the advantage
of defensive positions that have been
dug in and prepared over the last eight
years and that's going to make it an
extraordinarily difficult nut for the
russians to crack
and i think that with all of the support
that the ukrainians are getting from
around the world there's every chance
that the ukrainians can see them off
uh our political correspondent tomorrow
cohen joins us morning tc
i mean the minister's really talking a
very good game but we should be under no
doubt i mean the ukrainians are under an
awful lot of pressure and they continue
to need as much assistance as we and
others can provide indeed the government
are announcing more support all the time
we heard from the defense secretary
yesterday about the possibility of us
sending uh tank with the poles sending
soviet-era tanks to ukraine and we
backfill and they're talking about
all kinds of um military um equipment
but also things like ambulances and fire
engines which we're going to hear more
about today but how does this all end
well boris johnson was the first western
leader to say on his india trip they
sometimes always get bit too candid when
they're abroad he said that there was a
realistic possibility that russia might
win the war he was the first western
leader to say that caused some
consternation in eu capitals no one's
quite sure how this is going to pan out
james heapey was there saying look it's
not inevitable that some of these cities
in eastern ukraine will fall and we're
going to try and give the ukrainians
everything they can to try and fight for
them but certainly this may play out
over a very long time and there's little
illusions uh in number 10 and elsewhere
and that this is not going to be over
quickly i wonder if the public knows
that however tomorrow for now thanks
very much indeed
well let's stick with the topic we can
speak once again to the former director
of policy planning at nato fabrice
pottery uh fabrice lovely to see you
again i wonder if we could start if
possible with what's taking place
in the east of the country i put the
question to james cp the armed forces
minister of the ministry of defence this
morning is there an inevitability that
the russians will take territory in that
part of the country
i think nothing is
should be dismissed at this stage but uh
clearly the message we heard from
including the u.s uh defense secretary
is that
this is still you know the jury is out
as to whether the russians are going to
prevail or not so it's very much in our
hands and and in the support we provide
to the ukrainians that can decide
whether the russians are indeed going to
grant more territory going to kill more
people or on the contrary whether
they're going to do one of their
so-called tactical withdrawal which is
what they have done essentially for the
first part of this war when they had to
withdraw from from kiev and from other
cities so i think it's still very much
open and it's very much dependent on on
the kind of support we are providing to
the ukrainians
wonders though whether vladimir putin's
ambitions are are limited to ukraine i
mean what do you make of the the
suggestion that moldova could soon find
itself in the in the firing line so to
speak transition of course
a series of blasts we were seen there
yesterday
well of course nothing should be
dismissed with vladimir putin but what
he's also known for is to open
alternative fires of france to distract
our attention
i i think that the reality is that his
forces are now in the eastern dombats
and they're kind of digging in
for potentially a long war of attrition
and destruction and and the question
really in our hands is how can we push
back so yes moldova could be next if you
look at the the geographic position but
really the russians have not managed to
seize odessa so it will take a lot of
forces and capabilities from them to do
what they have failed to do over the
past few weeks
we heard yesterday of course
following his visit to the ukrainian
capital from the u.s secretary
secretary of defense he suggested that
the american ambition is to see russia
diminished so that an invasion of this
type could never be seen again i mean
first and foremost do you think that is
the strategy and second was it wise to
say it out loud i mean it doesn't
exactly provide incentive to vladimir
putin to withdraw
i think it's all cards on the table
quite frankly and and what he said was
quite candid and actually i think shared
by
many governments and especially nato
governments
however it is also clear that some other
nato government including probably
france is not of the same view it's more
about oh we have to stop this war
as soon as possible and and somehow
bring russia back into a more kind of
mainstream uh power uh on top so i i
think these are where there's some deep
diversion diversions between
the us uk and and some other nato
members but but i do think that goal is
is very uh sensible one because clearly
now we see that we just can't let putin
get away with it once again and do
another uh ukraine or another launch
another huge war in a couple of years so
i think that goal is is sensible but
then gold is obviously also risky of an
escalation with russia
for priests supposedly always good to
see you thanks very much for joining me
very much
tonight at 7 00 pm we will be discussing
the progress of the war in ukraine so
far and exactly what putin's next move
could be damn it merlin will be here
with a panel of guests that's war in
ukraine put into the next move at seven
o'clock tonight
johnny depp was back on the stand
yesterday in his defamation trial
against ex-wife amber hart the court
heard recordings of the actors arguing
while depp described the physical and
emotional anguish the relationship put
him through so guys dave david blevins
has this report but at first just a
warning it does contain audio recordings
of the couple arguing offensive language
and graphic descriptions of injuries
[Music]
far from the glitz and glamour of their
days on the red carpet together johnny
depp and amber heard were in the
courtroom for a third week jurors
listening to audio recordings of them
arguing
put your cigarette down on someone else
you have consequences for your actions
that's it shut up fat ass yeah
you got me there
depp and heard are suing each other over
an opinion piece she wrote about
domestic violence in another recording
while discussing the media storm around
them she appeared to advise depp to talk
about his own experience as a victim
tell people it was a fair fight and see
what the
jury and judge think tell the world
johnny tell them johnny depp i joined up
man i'm i'm a victim too jeremiah
depp's former house manager who told the
court his first job was in buckingham
palace revealed he'd been the person who
found the tip of the actor's finger
following a ride between the couple
i walked back upstairs to the kitchen
and
put it
got a bag you know little um
little plastic bag put the fingertip in
there set it on top of some ice in in
this plastic kitchen container
johnny depp who has now finished giving
evidence said he'd built his captain
jack sparrow character from the ground
up and described being dropped from
pirates of the caribbean as having
become guilty until proven innocent
david blevins sky news washington
tesla billionaire elon musk has promised
to prioritize free speech on twitter
after striking a deal to buy the
platform in a takeover worth more than
34 billion dollars at pounds i should
say actually it's even higher at the
move comes his twitter faces mounting
pressure from critics to regulate
misinformation on the site we're joined
now by former british army intelligence
officer philip ingram philip very good
morning morning
what on earth do you make of this i'm
not talking about the amount of money
because frankly you know it's traded
well up until now it's been traded
publicly but what do you make of the
world's richest man taking on perhaps
one of the world's most significant
social media platforms well i think the
amount of money is important because
here's where i'm going to embarrass
myself with my maths but 44 billion
dollars is about 150 just over 150
dollars a person for every user on
twitter yet twitter's free elon musk
clearly thinks that every single
individual is worth that amount of money
and that is because um people's data is
the new gold and he sees that data as
being critically important and the the
key question here is what is he going to
do with that data to get his 150 plus
dollars per person uh value out of it
and make profit on top of that
when i was reading kind of elon musk's
statement yesterday after the
announcement the one line that left out
to me was his ambition to authenticate
the world to give everyone at that blue
tick up until this point when one of the
advantages of this platform of twitter
has been the anonymity that it affords
you can go on under an assumed name and
assumed identity if you so desire
well that anonymity as most twitter
users will have experienced leads to
an awful lot of abuse because people
feel as if they can hide behind the
anonymity for those anonymous
individuals out there you can't hide you
will be known but it's much better if we
can get a more assured platform and that
will
enable hopefully a better debate that's
out there but the important thing is
understanding who can actually
manipulate the data behind it because
it's getting those feeds into your
personal feed it's been shown beforehand
where big data has been manipulated uh
for example the cambridge analytical
scandal that happened a few years back
um that it can influence people and
influence people's thinking and we have
to make sure that elon musk is not in a
position where he can abuse his position
from owning such a powerful platform
so when when elon musk says it says that
free speech is the bedrock of a
functioning democracy and that his
takeover is all about free speech you're
not exactly taking him at face value
well you know his motivation is not uh
to provide an enabled democracy his
motivation is to make money as he does
with all of his business ventures
because he's a businessman so he's going
to do something to make money he he does
that through a free platform it's free
for us to use but uh he he targets
advertising at us um we have to make
sure that that advertising is just for
goods and services that we want it's not
done in such a way to try and manipulate
the way people are thinking to
manipulate the stories so that it
adjusts people's political thinking or
in other in other ways and there there's
some very good research and very good
science out there about how the power of
messaging can be used to manipulate the
way people think no matter how free
thinkers individuals think that they are
if it's targeted in certain ways um it
can be very influential and for one
individual to have that um might be a
little bit too powerful
i i do wonder though just how this kind
of free speech twitter will fare we've
got an online safety bill going through
parliament at the moment where you could
be you receive pretty significant fines
for content which is entirely legal but
termed an inverted commas harmful
well i think the online safety bill is
critical um
too often people are hiding behind the
excuse of free speech and actually the
power that the people that own these
platforms have is enormous and they have
to take responsibility for some of the
content that's on there you know if the
content is abusive if the content is um
suggesting violence or suggesting you
know anything that is that would be
inappropriate if you're talking to
someone face to face um then the the
those that are owning the platform need
to have some form of incentive to force
them to police it and that's why you
know i think the online harness bill is
definitely the right way forward it's
going to be interesting to see the
detail in it and how it's applicable
across the globe
philip ingram great to have you on the
show this morning thanks for being with
us thank you thank you
now you may well have noticed the world
has been grappling with covet for around
two and a half years now with countries
continuing to approach the virus
differently
currently the chinese capital beijing is
bracing itself for possible lockdown
after rising cases with around 26 new
infection 26 new deaths reported over
the weekend compared to that here in the
uk now there are no virus restrictions
but just taking a look the seven day
average uh on the 24th of april thirty
nine thousand and seventy seven twenty
three thousand seven hundred and ninety
one new cases uh reported yesterday uh
let's speak to someone who's been on
this program more than a few times the
whole special envoy for the global
covert 19 response dr david navarro good
to see you again doctor hello hello to
you hello to viewers how did you do
thank you very much um could we start
with china how concerned are you that we
are seeing such dramatically different
approaches to dealing with covert in
various parts of the world i just
mentioned here i mean new cases reported
here almost 24 000 you go to china where
there are reporting a handful of new
cases in comparison and they're
preparing to lock down the capital
yes it is amazing isn't it
i think it will take still
a few more months for
different
leaders around the world to come
together and work out the best way to
deal with kovid right now there's still
a bit of a debate
do you try to prevent the covid
completely with really strong measures
as is being applied in china or do you
basically let things go and let the
virus do what it wants to which is
becoming the the british style
and of course those of us in the world
health organization as we tend to do say
look it's a middle path and the middle
path is to keep that virus back and to
stop it just infecting everybody because
it it can have long-term effects and it
causes a lot of absenteeism but at the
same time to try not to lock down a
whole society
because the economic and social
consequences are terrible and it's that
middle path that more and more countries
are moving on to
but just to focus on on those countries
that you say are are letting things go i
mean again on the 24th of this month
here in the uk we reported 320 deaths i
mean
is it the case that countries which are
doing similar to that which we're doing
here in the uk
is this just pursuing herd immunity by
by another name
well it would be good if herd immunity
really
is a regional object a reasonable
objective
just for everybody to know
and i'm sure you've all seen it
you get infected with covid and if
you're unlucky
you get infected again a few months
later why is that because
unlike with other infections once you've
had covered the body defenses
actually wane over time and in older
people or if people with less strong
immunity they wane quicker and that's
why we get infected again and again and
that's why we're not ever going to have
complete immunity of the whole
population it will always be declining
over time and that's why we will have
regular surges of disease just
fortunately because we do tend to be up
to date on our vaccinations those surges
will not be associated with a lot of
death there's still far too many people
dying but it's not the big big numbers
that we saw uh over a year ago
just then should we now be be looking
towards i can't believe i'm saying this
and i haven't even you know put my
swimming trunks on and been to the beach
yet we're this side of summer but should
we already be looking ahead to what
might be coming down the pipeline autumn
autumn and winter this year i mean we
always see it haven't we've seen it
every year we've seen that dip over the
summer months because of course
respiratory illnesses not transmission
it's transmitting in the same way we
should not be preparing for a surge
coming later on this year
absolutely my language is like this
prepare for your surges
prevent transmission when the virus is
around and protect people who are most
at risk three p words
i believe that people are the solution
and with those concepts of preparing
preventing and protecting
we will be able to deal with this there
will be surges we should be ready and
the people in the hospitals and in
public health offices they're already
hard at work because they know
what's coming uh down the pipe as you
say
uh briefly if we can talk to nabarro
masks i mean should we all just be
wearing them as a matter of course in
europe well i certainly believe that we
should be wearing masks in places where
we're confined uh such as for example
indoor hospitality i believe we should
be maintaining physical distance but
that doesn't mean that i believe
everybody should be locked down it's
just i think the masks still are useful
here they are
doctor indeed well well done dr david
navarro good to see you hope you're well
and we'll speak again thank you i am
well i'm good good best wishes to you
ah now let's leave you with some lovely
pictures uh these
are two crew members on the rrs sir
david attenborough and they have been
this is very interesting the first same
sex couple to marry in antarctica i have
to admit i wouldn't be wearing a kilt up
there uh stewart's eric born and stephen
carpenter have been together for 20
years they were married by will whitley
the ship's captain at the british
antarctic surveys rotherham research
station and again i will say kilts
they're fine if you're in scotland yeah
and antarctic i'm not quite so sure
anyway stick with us uh coming up after
the break the armed forces minister
james teepee told me it's not inevitable
that towns and cities in eastern ukraine
will fall to russia we will be back
there with our team of correspondents
producers and cameras on the ground to
bring you all the latest after this
[Music]
you